good morning Hank it's Wednesday Today I
want to tell you the strange but
revealing story of how I suddenly became
a hit with old people by the way I'm
breathless because I've just come from a
workout in my pizza John football jersey
keeping dry with my pizza John hand
towel and of course keeping hydrated
with my pizza John now Gene all of this
magic is available only at petemist.com
and only for the next 12 days okay so
this is a story of recommendation
algorithms Amazon books and the future
of publishing so last May my book The
anthropocene reviewed came out in
hardcover but not in paperback
traditionally hardcovers are published
about a year before the paperback comes
out the hardcover is a little more
sturdy and has some bells and whistles
like they have these nice bands on the
spine they may be imprinted with secret
pictures of Tuatara Etc and the idea is
that hardcore fans will pay extra to
read the book before the paperback comes
out and also to have a beautiful object
and because it's more expensive
everybody Publishers bookstores authors
makes more money like for context with
my novels I make about twice as much per
hardcover sale as I do per paperback one
but all of this like so much of
traditional publishing is of course
wildly Antiquated right maybe it made
sense in 2005 when my first novel came
out but it certainly does not make sense
today when people expect with good
reason I think to be able to read
however they want whether that's via
ebook or audiobook or hardcover or
paperback but because of these
Antiquated publishing strategies there
is no paperback of the anthropocene
reviewed unless you count the large
print edition which looks like this and
is designed for people who want or need
to read larger type so some percentage
of people who buy the anthropocene
reviewed from Amazon just click
paperback and accidentally buy the large
print edition and then also because this
is my first book for adults I am lucky
enough to have many older readers or
other people who benefit from large
print editions and that's another
percentage of the sales but neither of
those is the primary reason why I
recently became one of America's leading
large print edition authors the reason
or at least the biggest reason is that a
while back the hardcover of the
anthropocene reviewed went out of stock
at Amazon because a bunch of people
ordered it all at once for Sharon
McMahon's book club like Amazon sold
thousands of hardcovers in a single day
and then they didn't have any more but
they did have the large print edition so
the algorithm began marketing that as
the primary edition of the book because
it was the only print version they had
for sale and so people bought a lot of
the large print edition in fact they
ended up buying more of the large print
edition than they had of the hardcover
before it went out of stock and somehow
in that process Amazon's algorithm
convinced itself people prefer the large
print edition of This Book of essays
that's the one they want and so that's
the one I'm gonna show them and so for
the last four months whenever people
search for the anthropocene reviewed on
Amazon they are disproportionately
likely to be shown the large print
edition and that is the story of how the
large print edition of my book The
anthropocene reviewed became a USA Today
bestseller but the story doesn't end
there because the Amazon algorithm
believes the large print edition is the
canonical edition of the anthropocene
reviewed and because it therefore sells
very well Amazon also thinks that other
people who mostly buy large print
editions will of the anthropocene
reviewed and this results in more large
print edition sales to people who read
those books tend to be elderly and over
the last couple months I have seen a
huge surge in fan mail from older people
which has been so lovely they're not
reading the book because of my tick
tocks or the Fault in Our Stars they've
never heard of me but they still like
the book or at least if they don't like
the book they don't write me the point
is a tiny algorithmic Quirk has created
a self-reinforcing cycle of phenomenon
needless to say also seen Elsewhere on
the internet what's the lesson here well
first Publishers need to get with the
times and publish both special editions
for people who want them and inexpensive
paperbacks for people who want those
also two algorithms are human directed
and humans are algorithm directed in
ways we do not fully understand oh and
also three get all your pizza Miss stuff
before it's too late pizzamist.com Hank
I'll see you tomorrow